disrupted routines during this pandemic
may be hard for many of us but the
transition can be especially difficult
for people on the autism spectrum and
their families during this world autism
month Jamie wax shows us how some are
coping and how the pandemic is
highlighting the value of autistic
people in the workforce I'm not a
trained therapist I'm not a trained
teacher and I'm trying my hardest
Kristen Teodoro has a lot on her plate
these days like many of us the Long
Island mom of two was forced to make a
big shift when social distancing became
the norm across the country her
four-year-old son Hudson is nonverbal
and on the autism spectrum he relies on
speech and occupational therapy in
addition to classroom learning and we
don't really see when it's gonna end
it's really scary for us according to
the CDC one in 54 children in the u.s.
is diagnosed with an autism spectrum
disorder and as kovat 19 continues to
interrupt everyday lives
groups like Autism Speaks are now
offering free online resources to help
those children and their families
transition Donna Murray is head of the
autism treatment network many in our
community find comfort and routine so
this has really disrupted their lives in
big ways that comfort and routine was
also a concern for Otacon an IT services
company that says 2/3 of its workforce
is on the autism spectrum
David Aspen all runs their US operations
what we found is through utilizing a lot
of the business tools that we're now
using in a work from home environment
we're really helping our analysts grow
when you talk about this it seems almost
like a silver lining to everything
that's happening to business during this
pandemic yeah I think it's opening eyes
to the possibilities of neuro diversity
within the workplace employment is
something we'll Colette struggled with
for
years he counted himself among the
estimated 85% of autistic adults who are
unemployed or underemployed after a
string of dead-end jobs he found the
training program at Otakon as soon as
the instructor at Otakon started writing
this thing out on the board I went I
know how to do that I really enjoyed
doing that I think I found my place that
must have been an incredible feeling it
was easy and amid all of today's
uncertainty these glimpses of
opportunity and acceptance are also
creating hope some ways your
four-year-old son could not be coming
into the world as an autistic person at
any better time in history do you agree
with that 100% my husband and I talk
about it all the time
which brings us comfort for CBS this
morning
Jamie whacks New York